the most salient lesson of our work is
actually that we can solve this problem
maybe it sounds a little trite but I
think I mean when I came to this and I
think I would speak for you know
thousands of people who have joined
Teach for America who come to this
feeling like the world should be a
different way you know it isn't fair
that we have thirteen million kids in
our country who are growing up below the
poverty line who you know by the time
there are in fourth grade are you know
already three grade levels behind fourth
graders in high income communities half
of whom will not even graduate from high
school the half who do who will have an
eighth grade skill level you know one
out of ten of our kids and low-income
communities will actually graduate from
college so we've all come to this saying
this shouldn't exist like we have to do
something about this and I think what
has happened to us is that we've come to
realize not only should we do something
about it we actually could do something
about it and and really we could attain
a world where all the kids in our
country have the chance to attain an
excellent education and I think what's
led us to that initially was what we saw
from initially a fraction of our core
members who going through their own
learning curves figured out how to
actually put their kids on a different
trajectory you know so now today because
we've learned so much from the initially
small fraction of teachers who were
affecting dramatic gains and their kids
achievement you know we've learned a lot
from them and have fed those lessons
back into our training and support
models and and I've reached a point
where now many more of our teachers are
extremely successful with their kids and
so now we see evidence across any sort
of community from remote rural areas to
our hardest pressed urban areas you know
at the elementary level middle school
level at high school level we see just
hardcore evidence that when kids are
given the opportunities they deserve
they excel you know kids facing some of
the greatest challenges
poverty in in our country so seeing that
at the classroom level and and now
seeing through you know a number of our
alums would teach very successful and
see their kids going off into nearby
middle schools or whatever and would see
that those schools weren't giving the
kids the opportunities really that they
deserve to continue on the new
trajectory and and that led a number of
them to go out and pioneer these very
high performing charter schools you know
and there are many others in the country
now as well who who are you know growing
this generation of schools and
low-income communities that are taking
you know whole schools full of kids in
in low-income communities and putting
them on a track to graduating from
college and so now we see not only at a
classroom level but at whole school
levels that it is completely possible to
do this and so whereas you know I think
back to 15 years ago you know I think
that the public evidence we had that it
was possible to take kids growing up in
urban in rural areas and actually put
them truly on a level playing field was
the movie Stand and Deliver remember you
know Jaime Escalante the the teacher in
South Central Los Angeles who two of the
classic kids and got them to pass the AP
calculus exam I mean incredibly
inspiring story but I think at some
level I think the movie served the
purpose of making it seem like here was
this one person who was who's just a
hero you know and and and many many
people concluded that that you know it's
something you know that we couldn't
figure out like something magical or
elusive about that teachers impact and I
think you know you could probably count
on one hand and even that is generous
that the number of schools 15 years ago
that we're taking whole schools full of
kids and putting them on a level playing
field and I just think wow you know how
far we have come in 15 years where you
know we ourselves just within the
context of Teach for America and
certainly there are many successful
teachers outside of Teach for America
but we could point to hundreds of
teachers who have
affected just dramatic gains in their
students achievement levels and we could
explain exactly how they do that we know
today that there's nothing magical and
nothing elusive about attaining real
success with kids in low-income
communities you know it's it's about
it's about all the basics you know
there's no there's no way around the
very hard work of getting it done but
there's nothing elusive about it and and
today there are thought to be 200
schools in low-income communities that
are really accomplishing this at a whole
school level so the conversation today
is completely different you know whereas
before we were trying to figure out can
this be done on any sort of scale today
we know this can be done and and the
question is really just okay how do we
how do we affect the system level change
is necessary to truly ensure that all
kids have access to teachers and schools
that will put them on a level playing
field